c'est une séquence qui a fait le tour
des médias qui monfils qui a 8 ans mad
world is et le vainement de pia existait
vraiment c'est que de vivre celle de
cette jeune mère de famille qui témoigne
du problème de la mixité dans les
banlieues mardi sonia mabrouk revenez
sur le sujet dans son émission made in
your sur ces news et donner la parole à
son intervenante et elisabeth lévy dans
ces quartiers vous n'avez plus de
boucherie non halal vous faites un
cieutat si vous mangez pendant ramadan
et compris d'ailleurs si vous avez une
tête d'arabe
une sortie qui n'a pas manqué de faire
réagir sonia mabrouk il a directement
recadrer et qui lui a demandé si elle
avait elle aussi une tête d'arabe
ce à quoi elle a répondu que vous êtes à
une origine mais ça n'a rien de saint
constant
alors ils n'ont peut-être pas maintenant
l'affairé on l'applaudît pas à annoncer
un délire quoi oui non mais ho petite
pancarte pour vous est-ce qu'elle a
dérapé
elisabeth dur a dit non l adl a dérapé
bien sûr mais elle doit être condamnée
entièrement par sa chaîne sur la
question c'est at elle dérapé
ça a changé lol alors si oui mais ça ne
va pas changer merci oui moi oui je suis
choqué par ses propos en fait j'ai
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui quand vous
êtes éditorialistes c'est un espèce de
bing ou de mots clés qu'il faut cocher
pour faire une phrase qui va être
reprise et qui va faire du buzz c'est
islam ramadan musulman arabe donc la
voile elle que je toutes les cases ça
choque et bravo à sonia mabrouk de
l'avoir reprise de volée directement et
de l'avoir recadrer ce que je pense
c'est un peu compliqué de tenir ces
propos même si c'est bien d'avoir toutes
les opinions sur les chaînes info elle
exclut elisabeth lévy toujours elle crée
le scandale
sa rhétorique c'est toujours la même
c'est toujours contre les musulmans donc
je suis choquée elle devrait être
sanctionné c'est inadmissible sanctionné
toujours la frontière de l'incitation à
la haine à la elle y est presque
allez allez avec nous elle a dit
considérer ma phrase comme étant raciste
ni raciste c'est ce qu'a dit elisabeth
elle est avec nous et merci d'être là
elisabeth lévy mais bon ce soir
d'ailleurs je ne savais pas que je
risquais quelque chose et qu'il fallait
du courage pour vous parler je ne ferai
pas je ne me sens pas de menacer non je
n'ai pas du tout l'impression d'avoir
dérapé mais je trouve cette polémique
très intéressante c'est vrai parce que
elle révèle beaucoup de choses sur
l'antiracisme d'abord je crois
absolument pas un seul instant que
quiconque ait pu se sentir offensés
si vous voulez par l'expression tête
d'arabe parce que sauf si on considère
karam est une insulte sur une tête
d'arabe
c'est pas une
alors comment alors isabelle quand vous
expliquer comment vous expliquer et 7,5
généraux prise chameau ça c'est une
insulte et c'est marrant je ne me
rappelle pas ce grand tollé tout c'est
offenser sur les réseaux sociaux
quand ça s'est produit c'était
extraordinaire si vous voulez au-delà de
cette indignation sur jouer vraiment sûr
jouer et la moelle écrite chochotte
séparer de parts et surjouée parti perd
par tous les gens qui prétendent être
renforcée ou qui prétendent que ce
serait raciste de dire ce qu'on voit si
vous volez mais peu importe je n'ai
jamais dit ça quand même chose insultant
que c'était une description c'est voler
par exemple je ne sais pas il ya des
gens si l'on rencontre un grand blond
aux yeux bleus il sera peut-être pas
suédois mais ce pourrait me dire mais il
a une tête du suédois
bon alors mais l'emportent alors si les
appelle ça je te dis attendez là la
journée alors parce que comme je vais
vous dire oui c'est que il y a dans cet
antiracisme qui devient dingue
à force de vouloir chercher des racistes
il ya en plus une contradiction
complètement folle c'est à dire que d'un
côté ça paye 50 ans ou 30 ans qu'on nous
dit ya les minorités visibles visible
visent in il faut que la visibilité il
faut plus de visibilité bon ba visible
le ça veut dire quelque chose ça veut
dire que ça tu vois un certain type
civique par exemple et là c'est
formidable l'iphone la visibilité mais
si on voit ces minorités visibles alors
là on vous dit que vous êtes raciste et
par ailleurs il ya des quartiers où on
s'appelle mon frère où mon cousin
sur la base du type physique et vous
laisser c'est quoi ça près de castaldi
mes frères eh bien oui si vous voulez
donc c'est vrai on peut voir et qui
n'est ni un jugement de valeur
évidemment non quelqu'un lui une bande
beurre tout le monde peut voir on
n'aurait pas droit de le voir ça me
rappelle la polémique autour de sa
malheureuse arbitre qui pour identifier
un noir milieu 4 blanc avait dit lenoir
bon bah ça n'est ni dépréciative ni
acrobatique alors aidé à mettre dans
minute mais à nicolas pernikoff qui veut
réagir là-dessus alors elle agissait là
la réponse d'elisabeth en a mais moi je
veux réagir un truc c on peut pas passer
ça comme ça mais le coc quand vous dites
qu'on se fait insulter en main jean
pendant le ramadan je suis désolé mais
je sais que j'arrive à quelqu'un tomber
personne mais ce que ça vous est arrivé
enfin je les amène en outre à dangereux
de sortir des choses pareilles alors ça
ne m'est pas arrêtée à moi excusez moi
si vous pensez que ça alors je vais vous
dire la seule chose c'est que évidemment
ça n'est pas de globalia des quartiers
on peut manger pendant le ramadan mais
oui si vous voulez quand vous êtes dans
un autre dans certains quartiers il
plane is et que vous mangez vous aimerez
responsabilités sur la question répondu
à ma question c'est est-ce que vous avez
bien d'extrêmement rabe est ce qu'il ya
des gens qui soutiennent à eux mais
comme un ver des gens qui trouvent en
pensant que et bien pas ça pue turbulent
dans leurs interventions alors à cette
polémique c'est une polémique a été
montée ps huy où nicolas non mais ça n'a
rien à voir ce que est ce que j'ai je
suis désolé je vous apprécient mais ce
que vous avez dit aujourd'hui est grave
d'ailleurs moi je pensais que vous étiez
pris les pieds dans le tapis pour vous
dire la vérité parce qu'on n'arrivait
pas à rebondir face à sonia mabrouk
vous avez quand même dit une chose vous
dit si vous mangez pendant le ramadan
vous fait insulter j'aimerais savoir je
me suis jamais fait insulter est ce
qu'il ya quelqu'un que vous connaissez
qui s'est fait insulter parce qu'il a
rallongé par un ramadan mais enfin c'est
l'idée des rentes versées alors que je
connais bien évidemment la seule chose
que je vous accorde sept jeunes
n'auraient pas dû avoir un propos aussi
globale j'aurais dû dire
hilary dire que si vous mangez pendant
le ramadan vous pourrez même mais
puisqu'on parle de ça et de cet extrait
ce que j'ai aussi dit et j'aimerais vous
faire entendre
c'est que si cette dame tel dame est
très aimable ce plan qu il n'y ait pas
de pierres dans la classe de son fils
mais si elle avait appelé son fils
pierre ce qui lui a visiblement pas
traversé l'esprit visiblement et bien il
y aurait des pierres dans la flotte de
ton fils alors mais c'est un autre débat
géraldine maillet elisabeth vous
combattez les anti racistes mais
finalement vous c'est vous qui
racialisée qui exclue mais quand vous
dites à sonia mabrouk elle a une tête
d'arabe
vous pouvez pas dire car un bon pourquoi
en quoi j'exclus elle m'a demandé mais
les ballets afin de proposer en blanc
elle n'a pas une tête j'ai failli rcs
que est d'abord j'ai parlé elle m'a
demandé d'accord et coûteuses ce qui est
marrant c'est qu'en fait tout le monde
savait traduire ce que je voulais dire
et c'est vous qui monte sa sélection
parce que bien après
je répète que personne de sensé nous
cessons qui ont pensé parce que frau
était fallu de sensé ne peut y trouver
le dessus racistes à propos descriptif
mais non mais non non vous avez ou des
deux fois bleus présents dont celle là
j'entends l'objection
mais non vous ne me ferez pas croire que
vous trouvez ça nancy je pense que vous
jouez
non mais y aura des nouveautés votre
question attendait à la question à vous
poser géraldine vous avez une tête de
quoi vous voilà c'est pas du tout le
mois mais non mais moi en tant qu une
prochaine celle ci avait scié là qu'il
avait une tête de chat mohamed amor
suivra well as donné de quoi un bon moi
je moi je sais que j'ai rigolé pas ça
fait chier c'est paradoxalement c'est
une femme au sepa racialisée ouais c'est
vrai oui je dis pas les médailles et les
appels
elisabeth elisabeth lévy vous êtes
extrêmement intelligente et vous nous
fait croire que ce que ce que vous avez
dit aider et vidé de son sens or quand
vous dites une tête d'arabe et vous dit
vous nous dites ceni dépréciatif ni
péjoratif mais en l'occurrence vous
savez très bien que ça revêt un sens et
que pour certains ce sera dépréciatif et
ce sera péjoratif d'ailleurs gens
d'ailleurs pardonnez moi je termine mon
propos je termine mon propos de la la il
doit partir je sais pas lequel prendra
vite très vite
mais mais mais mais lampard cole eu
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs sonia mabrouk
gendre à ses que je trouve absolument
formidable oui à tickets psy cdp ni
dépréciative ni péjoratif elle n'aurait
pas tiqué elle n'aurait pas de monde la
formule de devoir de devoir peut-être
préciser votre prouver ça c'est sa
rivale inquiétez pas vous inquiéter pas
d'abord vous enverrai une très belle à
la une de cause géant bientôt c'était
évidemment pas dépréciatif mais c'est
pas ça que je veux vous dire parce qu'en
fait vous le savez très bien
est ce que je trouve extraordinaire si
vous voulez c'est que le problème n'est
pas de discuter de cette absence de
risques dit mixité pourquoi cette dame
n'a pas appelé son fils pierre par
exemple le problème c'est que j'ai dit
elle d'arabe
je parlais évidemment je n'ai pas dit ça
sonia de but en blanc elle va demander
est ce que moi j'ai une tête d'arabe je
lui ai dit oui je l'emmène et et si vous
voulez ce qui est assez logique
d'ailleurs pour quelqu'un qui est
d'origine arabe
fan de m
évidemment je non je ne crois pas si
vous voulez des mots les mots ont un
sens et je ne crois pas j'arrive bien
pascal praud grâce à lui pascal salut
pascal saint-amans pascal sueur sur ces
news pascal thomas savare bonjour les
amis tôt pascal je respecte les gens me
respectent et parce qu'allah nous ennuie
pas ce qu'on voyait bien cyrille qui à
l'escale
bonjour j'ai reconnu ma zabeth j'ai
reconnu elisabeth lévy chez très bas que
c'est isabelle morini-bosc avec une
coiffe avec une perruque un donc ne ment
pas elle va faire toutes les éditions
salah ya par ici mais je suis venu la
chercher à étendre à l'hosto drassm
ascal elizabeth
ça va avec ce jeu vous la recherche
juste la lazio n'est mabrouk son savoir
et d'amis désolé je ne peux pas
poursuivre ce débat le devoir m'appelle
basque est parce que c'est vrai que chez
nous tu es pas payer la ba oui donc valu
elisabeth juste avec sonia ça se passe
bien avec sonia mabrouk
mais ça se passe super bien avec ce nom
mais c'est ça qui est drôle si vous
voulez c'est qu'il ya une espèce de
mousse qui est monté parce que les gens
sont en vacances pour confinement ou je
ne sais trop quoi se taper sur elisabeth
lévy s'est quand même rigolo mais
franchement ça ne m'impressionne pas
pourquoi parce que je sais que personne
de personnes qui ne soit pas
professionnels de l'anti khalil
personnes dans l'est mais amy n'a pu se
sentir qu'au fond c'est ça qu'ils
avaient tous dit que vous êtes raciste
vous dit non ses décors mais ça je vous
laisse juge
allez bon bah merci enfin évidemment que
oui est ce que je veux maintenant de
vérifier oui elisabeth est ce que j'ai
une tête d'arabe s'esquisser d'arabe
un peu oui aux abonnés ce qu'elle est ce
qu'elle appellerait son fils mohammed et
d'arômes ou de juifs séfarades justement
on peut pas faire la différence
je ne chante tout pays traverse et son
fils mohamed hersi à la laisse et pour
l'amateur gilles verdez vous parlez
quand même elle parlait de quartier
islamisés elle dit si elle avait appelé
son fils pierre elle entendue vaut mieux
appeler son fils pierre que mohamed
souleymanou abdel ou je ne sais quoi
donc là quand même elles tracent une
hiérarchie entre les prénoms entre les
gens moi je suis profondément choquée
par ce qu'elle a dit sans la dénaturer
fabrice selon lui à dix après est là
elle est venu se défendre et voilà mais
voilà violent après on va voir ce qu'on
pense les téléspectateurs voient là
c'est violent parce qu'elle avait même
rajouté à propos de cette dame n'a imac
est une femme très bien qu'ils
souhaitent la mixité sociale je le
rappelle l a dit naïma c'est pas un
signe d'intégration extraordinaire la
culture française moi je trouve que
c'est une violence d'avoir dit ça l a
dit dans le même propos avec sonia
mabrouk delphine mais aujourd'hui je
pense qu'il ya des tensions entre les
communautés et aussi au sein des
communautés entre les gens qui sont très
pratiquants et les gens qui le sont
moins comme dans n'importe quelle
religion
donc c'est des choses peut-être qu'ils
peuvent arriver entre entre différence
de pratiquants et donc ce qu est ce qu a
dit cette dame je pense que dans le fond
ça peut éventuellement se comprendre
mais le problème c'est la forme et c'est
les mots quels employés c'est le ton
qu'elle employait parce que bien sûr que
des gens même entre différence de femmes
altrad un camps ce qui m'a le plus
choqué je le dis c'est ce qu'elle a dit
et c'est ce qu'a dit nicolas pernikoff
quant à dix pendant le ramadan et
insulter quand on mange un fruit
cette chirurgie pas un mec qui m'a
raconté cette anecdote alors on nous dit
rien franchement voilà ça je connais pas
ça va c'est moi pour moi c'est ce qui me
fait une fille le roux allez on va voir
ce qu'on pense les téléspecteurs oui 44
%
regardez et non à 56 ans